all right so I think an instruction sent
in an email the other day you guys had
to have download our our studio and all
the files just want to confirm everyone
was able to do that no problem okay
so right now if everyone could open up
our studio you should have something
that looks like this what's on the
screen right now and at any point I'm
talking feel free to stop you if any
questions you can shout it out raise
your hand really flexible on that and it
won't be rude at all okay so this is our
studio our studio is an IDE for our
integrated development environment and
I'm giving this tutorial on the
assumption that you guys have never done
programming language before but if you
have it will help with the session and
you'll still get something out of it
even if you do have experience in like
Python and C or anything like that
yeah okay so you have our downloaded our
studio no worries okay yeah and then
there should be two files on the Google
Drive this will lead to Google Drive it
shouldn't take long at all to download
okay so right now I'm just gonna give
you a quick quick tour of what our
studio is just so when I do call things
out you'll know what I'm talking about
so right now what I just did
I'll just do that again I opened up a
new script so I clicked on this top left
and let me know if you need me to make
it bigger and I just clicked our script
and so right now there are four basic
elements to our studio on the top left
we have our scripts in which we type our
commands and then we could run it on the
bottom left is where our console is this
is where everything is actually run so
for example if I do something like five
plus five on the bottom here will run
right there
I could also type it up here and then
from here run it and they'll run on the
bottom left on the top right is our
global environment that's where
variables get assigned and that's where
you could see him so for example if I
sign and I'll let you know what all this
syntax means in the tutorial I'm just
giving you a quick summary if I sign
seven to a you'll see it right here
on the bottom right is our plots
packages things like that I will get the
more of that later not going to go too
in depth into it now but this is our
Studio IDE unlike Python where you have
like spider anaconda Jupiter notebook so
many and people have no preferences
almost everyone who uses our uses our
studio so I'm going to close that out
there don't need to save that and if you
could all open the file that you
downloaded before the session or if not
it's also located right here in this
tiny URL link and this is what we're
going to go through today and if you
want to query your environment you could
just click this broom right here and
then you'll be good to go okay so
anything prefaced with a pound symbol or
a hash tag you can call it now is a
comment so anything that's a comment
will not be run in your council when you
run it and so all this right here
everything in green that the our studio
or our IDE conveniently highlights that
all denotes that it's a comment and so
if you want to run just one line and let
me know if I'm going too fast you just
go down need to rewind and save
something again that's all completely
fine as well
so anytime I want to run one line there
are many different ways you can do it in
our studio for example line 14 if I want
to run that I could highlight all of it
and then click where I'm sorry
press command enter or if you're on PC
control enter and I could run that right
here and on the bottom left pane in the
council you'll see one plus one and then
you'll see a comment addition but you'll
see that the comment didn't run one plus
one our expected output - right if I
wonder on multiple lines at once I could
highlight multiple lines so if I
highlight both these lines command enter
you'll see that both of those ran right
there so very easy on how you run
scripts to the council if you want to
run just one line a quick shortcut
instead of having to highlight just go
to the line that you want it and hit
command enter okay so are naturally
supports
the basic operations you see
multiplication exponents division
modulus modulus if you're not familiar
with that think back to your elementary
school days when you divide a number and
you have a remainder that's what the
modulus is going to output so 12 divided
by 4 4 goes into 12 evenly modulus of 0
5 does not going to 12 evenly you're
gonna have a modulus of 2 any questions
there before I move on ok for those who
just walked in we're just going through
the script that's located in a tiny URL
link I'm just giving a quick
introduction of our studio and the
different functions involved there the
next thing we have our logic functions
and these are going to be very important
anytime you're processing through data
so I just want to give you a quick brief
err on what those are you have your
equals equals okay and so this is the
same thing as saying does 1 equal 1 they
don't say they don't use 1 equal sign
because that's already used for other
things so it's two equal signs to go for
logic and you're going to see this very
consistent across different programming
languages so does 1 equal 1 and we
expect yes it does and so that's going
to output true does 1 equal to line 23
no obviously false and so you have your
different operators I'm not going to go
through every one one lesson two greater
than this one is less than or equal to
that's how you would read that and then
this line 28 is isn't not equal to so
does 1 not equal 2 and yes that's true
so we expect the true and that's what we
get right here and also modulus is used
a lot to find if a number is odd or even
so when you divide a number by 2 if a
modulus is 1 then we know it's odd and
so that's the most common use case of
using a modulus next going into the
different types of variables in our so
we have numeric logic and character
which are the main ones that you're
going to see and there are different
ways we can assign variables in our I
would say it's mostly a preference thing
on whether
use one or the other but the two ways
are using this less than - which is just
an arrow or equal sign and again do not
confuse the one equal sign with the two
equal sign as this is more having to do
with logic are two things equal to each
other so if I sign five so the way I
would read this I'm assigning five into
a so I'm pointing into a and once I run
that command command enter I'll see it
on my top right my global environment
that a is now equal to five okay so
that's one way to sign a variable also
in the common it said you could also
sign it using the equal sign so if I run
this command line 35 you're gonna see
the top right change the seven because
I'm now I'm signing seven to a instead
of five you could also assign logic or
boolean z' into variable names as well
so B equals true we'll see that get
updated in top right global environments
and you could also assign characters or
strings in R as well and Co see a B and
C all right here conveniently in my
global environment anytime to confuse on
what is my what type is my variable you
can type in STR think of stands for
structure structure yeah I looked at a
box these I want to actually Tommy most
of what I know about our structure of
our and you can see CHR character and
what it actually is hello okay so that
might be important when you're
processing data like okay what is this
variable how do we treat it and there's
also a very interesting thing called
factors and I would say just be careful
of those because they do mess you up
when you're processing large amounts of
data and they kind of get hidden
underneath it but we'll get to that road
and we cross it okay any questions so
far all right moving on so in our main
point of our is for you know statistical
analysis data science and so you're
going to be dealing with vectors and
tables a lot that's probably your
biggest use case for our and so if I
want to assign a column vector in our
I could use this function so anytime you
see something with parentheses you're
usually talking about a function here so
for example what I mean by parentheses
I'm using the structure function see I
have structure and then it's something
inside my parentheses that denotes a
function same thing over here
see parentheses and then stuff inside my
parentheses that's a function so what
I'm doing right here is I'm creating a
vector so if I sign this one two three
four five in two vectors nothing more
than my variable name it's not any
special name in R and you'll see it get
updated in my environment you could also
put different data types in the same
vector this is in common but I just want
to do it just so you can see that you
can do it well what's going to happen
when you put in different data types
into this one vector it's going to
convert everything and so right here
you'll see that I put in one text and
true so this is a numeric this is a
string and this is a boolean all
different data types but when we put it
into one column vector you'll see that
converted all the text and you'll see
that denoted by right here CHR and then
all your variable name are all your
things you inputted into that column
vector okay so those are your column
vectors and vectors that you will deal
with a lot you can think if you use
Python you can think of them as like
your numpy arrays you could do a lot of
similar things in that okay so now you
can do a lot of different things with
the vectors okay so you can run what is
a min what is a max what does it mean
things like that and anytime you know a
function name but you're kind of
confused as to what it does you can do
this in our question mark and then your
function name and that will bring up the
help on your bottom right and you can
see exactly what it's going to do what
your inputs are and an example of it
usually at the bottom
so that's one way you can help you know
use our and figure out exactly what you
need to do in that so if I'm working
with my Veck one I promise we'll get two
different exercises later when you can
work and I stopped talking when an hour
and a half is just not a long time so
I'm trying to get to as much as possible
so I apologize for just blabbering up
here so if I see the minimum of vector
one we would expect one to be the output
because that's the smallest number in
there and which it is alcohol so run
these different commands max mean which
is average standard deviation as well as
the length what the length is is how
many numbers are in this vector that's
all length is if I want to get all these
numbers at once I could run summary of
ech one and they'll give you your 5
number summary like your quartile 1
quartile 3 mean and different numbers
like that
and so that's a faster way of doing it I
could also run different operations on
my different vectors so if I want to
multiply it I can do that so multiplying
vector
you see that Veck 1 is originally 1 2 3
4 5 and so if I multiply it by 2 which
is just one scalar number it's going to
multiply each of these numbers by 2 and
so 2 4 6 8 10 that's where it came from
I could do division exponents everything
that you saw up there with the basic
operators in R you can do a vectors as
well and so what I'm doing right here
I'm dividing vector 1 by 3 and then I'm
going to assign it to a variable name
called vector e ok and you'll see it
divided every single one of those
numbers by 3 all right we good so far
any questions okay so now reading in a
CSV file so rarely do you I guess the
most common use case of ours you're
analyzing data and rarely do you create
the data in R it's always getting it
from an outside source and so I want to
spend some time doing and also how do we
manipulate that data how do we visualize
it for actual purposes that we can use
so reading in the CSV file
I took this from Kaggle and so what I
want everyone to do right now is go to
the so in order to read the file you can
get it from its absolute directory for
example if I want to do that then I
could go to like my users you know and
then go all the way and find where that
file is located a more easier way and
more common way to set your working
directory too near where your file is
located and so you can use a relative
reference instead of an absolute and so
that way if someone else were to use it
too and they will be able to do it so
what I want everyone to do right now is
go to your top and you'll see a
drop-down called session ok so you click
on that and so everyone should be
following along right now going to the
top clicking session and then set your
working directory if that's the SV file
that you downloaded from here that sales
data is in the same file that you
download the R file you can just click
the source file location and then I'll
set that working directory to that or
else you can choose directory and then
find where you ever you put that CSV
file that folder you put it in and then
you could just set your working
directory there so all that's saying is
like we're level setting this is where I
want all my relative references to be
from and we could talk more about that
later if that's not clicking so I'll
give everyone a second to do that let me
know if you have any questions or
trouble setting your working directory
to where you put your CSV file and how
you'll know you did it right is if you
run line 69 and it runs no problem and
you have your sales data at the top
right so I'm going to pause right there
and wait for everyone to get the sales
data into their R studio because the
next exercises will be contingent on
this step so I'll give everyone a minute
to do that and if you have any problems
at all feel free to raise your hand or
if you're done you can just look up as
well
okay so we're gonna have an exercise in
about like 15 minutes so I know some
people are still trying to find how to
download it but just for the sake of
time I'm gonna move on and then once we
get the kind of check point I'll go back
and help the people who may need it oh
yeah yeah thank you so much your boss
yeah bus can more than help you with any
of this stuff okay so right now we have
our sales data load in we have it in our
top right environment and so we're good
to go we're good to start analyzing it
and do everything that we need to do so
we can first examine this data set just
see kind of like the details about it
one way to do it using the our studio
interface is we can click this arrow
right next to it and that will tell us
all the fields column names what data
type there are you can probably some
eyes that int is integer numeric and
those are the factors I said are pretty
nasty that could screw you up but these
are the different data types involved
and then you could also click on the
actual data set and it'll see the actual
table of what it is and so a
programmatic way to actually see this is
just doing view and then your variable
name which I called sales data and then
that's the same thing that's clicking it
on the top right pane okay
so right now all we're doing is just
seeing what our data is all about
looking at it making sure we have the
right data in and seeing the different
details about it okay the next thing I
can do is it could run a summary on the
data and if you remember from the top we
ran a summary on different vectors and
we saw like the five number summary you
can do the same exact thing on a data
table so if I run line 77 I'm gonna have
a huge output because there's so many
fields but it's going to give me a
summary of all the field
in this table okay
this table is 25 variables so it's gonna
give me 25 outputs one for each one
depending on if it's a numeric field
such as like order number isn't numeric
that's more of like a like an ID but you
can see it's still treated as a numeric
a better example would be like quantity
ordered when I ran summary on the data
table we can see our five number summary
if it's a factor it will give you a
count of the top whatever amount of most
common factors and give you the
frequency of them so for example yeah
order date we see the most common one
was on November 14 2003 and then they'll
group the rest as other just because
there's not enough space to output
everything so right now all we're doing
is components of an exploratory data
analysis seeing what our data is all
about seeing the different numeric
features about it um before we actually
start manipulating it which will be in
the next 10 minutes or so okay so we ran
a summary but let's say that that was
overwhelming 25 outputs one for each
column too much we can also run it on
individual columns so the way you can
call a column there are a lot of
different ways you can do it the most
simplistic way of calling a column in R
is calling the data set and then dollar
sign field name okay so and our studio
does support tab completion for helping
with column names as well as functions
so typing in your data sets and then
you'll see that all that pop up and you
can run that as well and then that'll
just give you the summary for that
specific vector okay and just like
vectors you can run any of those
commands max mean min standard deviation
okay so there's a lot of different ways
we can see what this data is all about
using summary as well as the same
functions that we use
in dealing with vectors any questions so
far
okay now we're gonna start working with
D PI R D PI R is a package and are
created to help with data manipulation
and so in order to use D PI R we first
have to install it and then we have to
attach it because right now if if our
studio came with everything already
installed that would be too heavy too
much memory used and so we only use it
we only attach it when we need to use it
and so that's kind of the premise behind
why we have to attach it and use it
every time so I'm gonna walk you through
right now how we would install a package
and also how also we would use it and so
what you have to do in order to first
install D PI R I think the easiest way
is using the UI to user interface go to
the bottom right click on packages and
now everyone should be doing this bottom
right packages install and type in here
D PI R and you want to download that
right there D ply are once you have that
written right there all you have to do
is click install make sure you leave
that checked install dependencies and it
will install D PI R for you I'll give
everyone a minute to do that and if you
need any help feel free to raise your
hand and Abbas or I can come and help
you
so right now all I'm waiting for is
people to finish installing Dvir
and then I'll know you guys are done if
everyone looks up and on the way if you
have questions if you're raising your
hand okay I think we'll continue then so
right now we have the PI are installed
and now we want to use it the way we can
use it is we can go here on the bottom
right and click on the check mark right
next to it the way I do it because
that's involves a lot of scrolling is I
just type in library and then your
package name which is dir and run it and
then you'll get some read which is OK
no fatal messages so I think we're good
to go
so everyone right now should have deep
IR installed and then also attach it
using this library function ok good to
go sounds good
okay so our different functions involved
in deep IR that we can use are extremely
useful for data manipulation and so I'm
gonna walk through two main ones are
also ones that I'm not including in this
tutorial well once you get a good grasp
on these functions and I think you'll
easily be able to pick up the other ones
and I also want to say that we are going
at a very fast pace going through all
this material the goal for this tutorial
isn't for you guys for your masters it's
for you guys to have an understanding
and just kind of quick quick brief run
everything so when you do go back on
your own you'll know where to start and
where to look and so don't feel too
worried if you have kind of a hazy
understanding right now so the first one
we're going to go through is a select
function does anyone have any experience
with sequel ok cool
it's same thing a sequel what columns
are you selecting and what columns you
want to return so the way I would run
the Select function is type in select
and the reason why I have everything
written out is because I
the most common air in we're using are
any programming language is syntax and
sort of way to avoid spending time
helping with syntax wrote everything a
lot for you but we will have a chance to
work on on your own later where you do
create everything from scratch
so select getting the columns that you
want there are gonna be two main
arguments to this function okay so the
first argument when I say argument you
could think of it like an input there
are two inputs to every two main inputs
every dir function the first argument or
input will always be the data set okay
so sales data is a data set that I'm
working with the next arguments before D
PI our first select function within D PI
R are the fields that you want returned
okay this can be up to as many fields as
you have in your data set in my sales
data I have 25 variables so I can put up
to 25 fields here and there could be
more if you create more in your sales
data which we'll get to later so if I
run this command right here then I'm
just going to get from my sales data my
quantity ordered and price each okay and
that's what selects gonna do but right
now when I run this command alone it's
just kind of running it throwing it in
the Council which is the bottom left
pane and just throwing it into space the
only time you can use it is if you just
physically look at it the more common
thing to do is you want to store it into
a variable name so you're not destroying
it in a space and forgetting about it
and you know disregarding it and so we
can assign it using that arrow syntax
that we talked about earlier so I'm
running that same function that I just
ran but this time I'm assigning it to a
variable name called select data
probably not the most creative name was
just to illustrate that you could assign
it or else you're just throwing it into
space and forgetting about it can't do
anything with it so
I run that right there I see my select
data same amount of rows 28 to 3 but
only two fields this time because we're
only selecting two columns okay so
that's select very similar to sequel
all you're doing is getting the fields
that you want okay the next thing is
arranged so if I want to the sequel
equivalent in a range will be order by
so you're just choosing what fields do
you want to order or arrange your data
by so again you called a dir function or
range I'm just using a range and then
your first argument for any dir function
is always a data set that you're working
with so let's select data this time so
I'm going to use a data set that I just
created from the previous step and then
I want to arrange it by price each by
default it's going in ascending order so
four characters that's a to Z for
numerix 0 to infinity
okay that's by default if I want to do
it by descending order from greatest to
least then I just put a minus sign in
front of the field name okay so these
are the two ways you can do it I labeled
the first one arrange ASC data which is
ascending and arrange des see descending
data and so I could do those two there
and then I'll have my both my data sets
but now they're ordered okay any
questions so far yes yes all the
arguments are case-sensitive so if I
were to type all variable names are case
sensitive all function names are K
insensitive just to be safe everything
in R is case sensitive yeah so if I were
to type in so she asks is everything
case sensitive and the answer is yes so
if I were to type in capital sales data
this will give me an error because it's
saying where your sales data it's not
because I typed a with lowercase if I
were to type and select instead of
lowercase select that would also throw
an error cannot find function select so
everything is case sensitive good
question
the next function I want to talk about
so we just went there to select and
arrange now we're gonna talk about
filter filter sequel equivalent is where
I probably guessed that by the name so
if I want to have my again first
argument to any D PI our function is
your data set and then how do I want to
filter it this is where we use the logic
functions that we talked about earlier
is it equal to is it greater than is it
less than that's how we use that's what
we're gonna use in our filter function
so if our first argument in our dir
function filter is our data set then the
second argument and third if you want to
have more arguments or more filter
conditions would be the actual condition
so right now right here I'm filtering my
sales data and I only want the state New
York and so this has a state field and
so with this state I only want to do to
New York notice I usually equals equals
and not just a one equal sign
okay run that if I click on that I'll
see that I only have my New York data
okay if I want to do two filter
conditions I could use an and operator
in our it's the ampersand symbol so I
want to filter to only New York and our
product line is classic cars okay and so
I can do that
and they'll filter to have New York and
classic cars as both and so now it's
gonna get a little interesting because
rarely do we just run one command a lot
of times we want to run filter and then
we want or we first want to select and
then we want to filter and then we want
to arrange it right you want to kind of
bodis dir functions and so if you want
to do that you have to assign it and
then lift that new variable put it into
the next argument and then just kind of
chain it in that way and so the way you
would do this and I'm going to I'm going
to tell you a long way first before we
get into the more easier way of doing it
is for example if I want to filter first
the only New York and classic cars I'd
run that argument first and so this
argument when I filter sales data to
just New York and classic cars I'm sure
you guys you can't see what I'm pointing
at I'm assigning it to filtered data
right so now I have a new table called
filtered data and run that there now
with this filtered data and you'll see
that sixty-eight observations 25
variables now I'm going to put this
table into the next argument or the next
command so now I want to select it I
only want to get quantity ordered and
price each okay so I'm not using the
sales data table anymore I'm using the
filtered data variable now and so I had
to run that so now I have a select data
that only has my quantity ordered and
price each for owning New York and
classic cars okay and so now that's my
select data now if I want to arrange it
by the price each I put my select data
into the first argument of their arrange
function and then arrange it by price
each right and so if I run that oops all
right then I have my arrange data that
was both filtered and selected it's kind
of tedious cuz you have to keep
assigning and then putting that there
and then that there and then you just
kind of have to chain it
luckily dir has this thing called piping
which kind of handles this problem for
us
I'm sorry I wrote right here it's kind
of T used to have to run the same
command twice so we lose a concept
called piping and all piping does
instead of having to keep assigning it
in that Congress final path what it does
it sends the output of one function into
the input of another function so rather
than having
to the recursive we just keep assigning
and keep going on it automatically does
that for you by sending the output into
the input of the first function so I'll
talk about what that means so now we're
going to do the same thing that we did
above in lines 116 the 180 I'm using
piping so like I said earlier the first
argument to any DPR function is always
going to be the data set and so sales
data is our original data set and so
what I'm going to do is use this piping
function or feature is denoted by
percentage sign greater than percentage
sign that's the actual piping syntax and
I'm gonna pipe sales data into the
filter function notice in this filter
function right here I don't have any
data set in my argument okay that's
because right here i pipe sales data
into the first argument right here okay
so I don't need it there anymore so
right now just looking at the
highlighted thing let's look at those
two you right there I have my sales data
I piped it into the filter the filter
then takes that data set and it only
gets new york and classic cars okay and
so if you remember earlier that filter
function is going to output a filtered
data set with just new york and classic
cars and so instead of assigning that
now i'm going to send that out put into
my Select function and again notice i do
not have a data set in this function
right here because i'm piping the output
of the filter function into the Select
function same logic going into the range
function okay
and so this command right here lines 123
to 126 is going to be the same thing as
116 to 118 and it's going to be a lot
cleaner and a lot less variable
assignment and you'll find it very
useful once you get the hang of it
I promise we'll just one more kind of
instruction and then we'll have our own
try the last thing I want to talk about
is mutate before exercise not the last
thing for this session what mutate does
is you create your own columns or edit
existing columns okay yeah I don't think
really think there's a sequel equivalent
directly one the one it's like a
combination of different things so for
example like any deep I our function the
first argument is sales data right now
I'm not using piping and so the way you
would use mutate is you have your new
new column name that you want to name it
I'm calling it discounted so discounted
is currently not in the original data
set and then I'm going to say its point
nine five times whatever your sales is
and that'll be your discounted data set
and so if I run that I'll have my
mutated data notice the original data
set had twenty five variables this
mutated data set now has 26 variables
because we added a new one called
discounted and this discounted was
created by multiplying sales by 0.95 and
so we can make sure everything around
okay and usually it'll just be appended
as a very last column and you'll see it
looks okay I'm not going to you should
check it but not gonna do that right now
this for the sake of time if I want to
do the same thing piping just so you
guys get comfortable with it line 132 to
line 133 same exact thing as line 130
what all I'm doing is piping okay so any
questions on Mutai
yes
I see so no it creates an entirely
different instance it's not like ya know
yeah so if you want to manipulate it in
place rather than having to create an
entirely new table really the way you
can do that is right here we created a
pipe data table right if I want to
mutate it in place rather than assigning
it to a new table name I could just
assign it to itself yes okay
so right now you guys are gonna have
your own chance I created some questions
q1 q2 and q3 I'm going over what we just
learned in the past 40 minutes so I'm
gonna give you guys some time to work on
that and also troubleshoot any problems
that you had previously if you feel like
you made unwanted changes to your data
set just run line 136 again and you'll
have a fresh sales data set if you want
to clean everything right here click on
this broom and then everything will be
empty but right now I'm going to take
this time or you guys are going to take
this time to answer question one two and
three and I'll be walking around to help
you guys with any questions that you may
have
hey that's okay okay okay oh yeah yeah
um so where did you download this you
know if order isn't okay it's in your
downloads okay um you don't have to move
it it's okay okay so it's here now it's
here
yeah I think you're good now so right
now we're yeah so first you have to
install it
Tyr
they're downloading and then I also want
to install this and then now if I read
this then I have my cell David
oh I'm pressing command enter yeah hey
how's it going yeah having trouble no
worries very sad
okay did you save it as a text file txt
or did it automatically do that yeah is
there any way we could read download
this PI data archive Oriole file if you
go
- I open it
okay so we have our file that we were
working with earlier and then you could
run everything just like highlighting or
just any things like that if I wanted to
read in my data file
I said my working directory I saw you
using like CV you could say yeah that
would be set working directory in our
and I think I'm good to go now and then
just make sure you install oh no no yeah
what can you use and yeah it would have
to use a piping actual okay so I
installed deeper and now attach it
and now my sales data is good yep
okay sir
oh the mode yeah yeah so what yeah
that's I like you yeah that's good I see
what you're going if that but what a
range is doing is all it's doing is just
arranging alphabetically so we have to
think of a different way to figure out
what is the most common way maybe
summary might help everything going okay
Hey
yeah uh-huh oh that's a good question
only if the one after is dependent on
the ones previous if it doesn't affect
that then it doesn't really matter what
order you do it in but it'll always go
from top to bottom oh yeah always yes
yes good point yeah so in so all your
arguments and yeah that's I should know
and bring it up to the class when you
use a function you always have to use
equal sign yeah
but when you sign a variable name you
could use either one yeah yeah
your vows healthy day Jesus really
wouldn't get everything earlier figured
out okay great thanks
you guys all good yeah okay yeah yeah
five use like a little hard
yes yeah so they'll be using the Select
function yeah
yeah it's all good okay
y'all go
oh yeah that you know what yeah I saw it
yeah I don't think mode exists so you
can use I don't think it's embedded
maybe there somewhere but usually for
that I use summary yeah that might help
you yeah exactly it's like a cut yeah
yeah everything okay here
just by show of hands how many got
through question three done with
question three okay question two okay
well go through question one too and
then I'll give you a little bit more
time for question three okay so question
one what is the most common deal size
and right now the way I'm doing it isn't
the only way to do it there are a
million different ways to do everything
here so if I wanted to see what the most
common deal size is I saw a lot of
people trying to use a mode function I
think that intuition is great because
usually if you you would expect
something like that to be there but
unfortunately an R there isn't so one
way to do it is using a summary function
and so I could just do of it right here
run that I see that medium is my most
frequent common deal size so I'm just
going to put in the comments what is the
average quantity ordered so I could do
it a lot of different ways one way to do
it is using a mean function and then I
get thirty five point oh nine another
way to do it is using a summary and then
I could extract that from there thirty
five point oh nine I did have one very
interesting question that I want to
bring up to the entire group is that
when you're using something like a
mutate function we saw that earlier
right here we saw we used discounted
equals 0.95 times sales and then the
person was asking why when I put an
arrow here instead because that's what I
said earlier that my preference is that
I get an error actually I don't get in
here um but that does bring up an
interesting point is that when you're
working with functions right now we
didn't specify the argument names so
what I mean by that let's say I'm
running a summary function like here
then I'll have to put in an argument
name of your object right and then my
object is my sales data or something
like that
well I didn't do any of that I didn't
specify what these arguments or inputs
were because our already kind of is
smart enough to figure it out based on
the order you put it in and so maybe
later down the road when you deal with
more complex functions and which things
will be optional you will have to
specify exactly what the argument is
like what is your data set what do what
are you looking at where right now fdpir
functions it's easy enough where the
first argument is always our sales date
or our data set and then arguments
they're after or what you want to do
with it
okay so we answer question 2
I'll give you guys two more minutes to
wrestle with question three and then
we'll move on to group by and summarize
and then also with grafting so if you
guys two more minutes feel free to help
the person next to you and you could
also look at deep ir on google if you're
done let's see the other functions in
epi are so give you guys two more
minutes
oh that's good okay I like that yeah
okay yeah so max will always output just
a numeric yeah so I don't know how you
do it using a max function but maybe
sorry
why if I play around this
okay like you could do like this if you
put in a table first and then extract
like the row name of where it's max
that's one way you could do it yeah
we load through question three now so
I'm just gonna follow these instructions
and then go through what one answer
could possibly be I think this one's a
little less flexible so people probably
the same thing so right away it says
create a new data set called q3 data and
so that's essentially telling you what
we want this variable name to be so I'm
going to use an assignment now I'm
working with sales data I'm going to
pipe that right into a so the first
thing it's asking is a new column so a
new column I'm thinking mutate so I'm
going to pipe that into a mutate
function I don't need the first argument
because I'm piping and then I want MSRP
revenue again equals MSRP times quantity
ordered and I just use tab completion
and then I'm going to pipe that into a
filter function and I want to have
figure out what the size deal field is
deal size thank you deal size is equal
to large and then pipe that again and I
only wants to like the columns order
number and all that so rather than just
typing it all out it's gonna copy and
paste and then finally I want it ordered
in descending order by sales so default
is a sending and so we want descending
so I'm gonna put that minus sign in
front of sales because that's why I
wanted to buy and then hopefully this
runs on no errors and I think we're good
and this would be our final data set
ordered by sales we see its descending
order so we greatest to east and I only
got the fields that we want okay so that
would be the final answer to question
three okay part five or the last thing
we're going to talk about in deep IR
before we move on to ggplot
and we will save some time at the end
for any questions unrelated to what
we're doing more on the broader scope of
our so group I had summarize so group by
will it's very useful same exact thing
in sequel when you're grouping by
aggregating function using some average
things like that it helps us solve
questions like what are the total sales
by region or by country you're like how
much did each product line sell that's
we're gonna use like a group I and
summarize function and usually these two
things group I and summarize they
usually go hand in hand I'm just like in
sequel if you're using if you're
grouping by you want some aggregate
function to do it by right so we're
going to talk about those both together
instead of separate entities and so I'm
going to do it the first way without
piping on just so you guys can continue
to see a similarity hopefully by the end
you'll just do everything by piping so
what right now I want to figure out the
total sales by country so I want to
group it by country so every unique
country I wanted to have its own row and
then the total sales next to it so
that's the first thing I'm doing right
here in line 161 and please note that
our row numbers may be different now or
our line numbers because you guys have
entered in your own code to try to
follow along where I'm at number five
number five right here run that group
data and that will have a new variable
and now that it's all grouped by country
I want to find out the total sales by
summing the sales for each country into
that uni country so I'm summarizing it
and now I have my summarized data and my
top right you can group it by multiple
fields so let's say I want to group with
by country and product line or grief
deal it's you can do whatever you want
and you can also do different functions
instead of sum like Max min mean and
parentheses that's counts and if you
want to do like a distinct count you can
do like unique your field name we could
talk
about that later but these are all the
different functions there's probably
more thinking you can do with a group I
and summarize statement so here's my
summarized data I have all my country
names and I have my total sales for each
of those countries okay
same exact thing using piping you'll see
it's a lot cleaner piping sales data
into my group I which I'm grooving my
country and then finding the total sales
it's gonna give me the same exact output
okay so try it on your own figure out
what the average sale is by product line
feel free to also test out other things
in this time as well so I'm gonna give
you guys about five minutes to figure
out the answer to question number four
yeah
oh so you want to okay so you want the
original data set and then you want to
append it like the total sales for that
country I was just going to suggest the
way to doing joins yeah yeah I know what
you're talking about
I only know I don't know the command and
argh yeah I would just do it through
like there's like a thing called merge a
merge function in R that's same thing as
joins though yeah
[Music]
okay
yes no no okay yeah no worries okay
chief combination yeah you mind if I
okay there we go
no no worries of you and then it's like
a pains Oh pains up here yeah and then
show all pains yeah mm-hmm use all
tabbing every time I walk by
okay we'll go through the answer
together so what is the average sale by
product line and I'm just gonna do it
entirely by piping so I'm gonna call it
average sales I know I didn't say what
you know what you don't even need to
sign it so sales data type that into
group I and I want to group it by
product line and then I want to pipe
that into summarize and then I want to
figure out average sale so similar to
mutate yet this if you don't specify a
field name for it it'll give you a
default one you can specify a field name
for it just like you would do with
mutate so average sale is mean of the
sale object still not found thank you
okay so I didn't assign it to anything
so it just threw it out into space but
if you wanted to save it for future
reference you could assign it to a
variable name any questions on group by
and summarize okay so that is our data
manipulation section now we're going to
go into data visualization the most
common way most common package used for
that and there are so many out there but
understanding ggplot will help you will
give you a good yes so let's see yeah
yeah that's a good question I've
actually never looked at the output of
it cuz I just always use it together so
right now I just ran the group I by
itself would see what happens
yeah so the question was how do we
visualize the group I before we actually
summarized it into aggregate functions
and right now I'm not aware of a way to
visualize that group I before actually
summarizing a boss do you know of any
way yeah no worries so we group I and
then we summarize but is there a way to
visualize what you're summarizing like
yeah I think it's just all involved in
the metadata that yeah yeah yeah good
question though this answer what you
were asking though okay okay
okay so ggplot2 most foundational remote
there's one below it like plot that's
already in our but what's most common is
ggplot2 you could do a lot of fun things
with it so same way in which we install
DPI art we're gonna install it ggplot2
so install on the bottom right pane so I
know a lot of people walked in late so
I'm just gonna walk your new steps again
on the bottom right pane there are
different tabs I'm gonna click on the
packages tab I'm gonna click on install
type in ggplot2 and click install leave
everything checked all the defaults give
it some time and it should be installed
and then before I after I install it I
also have to attach it using library so
I'm gonna do that right here okay so
there are so the way ggplot works is you
kind of have like you can think of it as
building blocks that you just keep
adding on to like you create your
original plot and then you want to
change colors so you add a building
block to do that then you want to add an
x-axis label so you add a building block
to do that and so once you understand
how it is kind of hierarchy works then
you'll be able to customize your own
graphs a great resource for it is what I
put in the comments this ggplot2 cheat
sheet and it might look a little
overwhelming right now but we'll talk
about what all how to kind of decipher
what all this means and then you'll be
able to do your own thing and customize
your own charts so that's what we're
gonna do right now so if I want to
create a simple dot plot I can use the
first argument to ggplot would be my
data set so we're still working in our
sales data and then we go into this
weird thing where it says AE es x equals
that y equals that you can probably
figure out what x equals
that and y equals that is those are our
coordinates to our plot AES is short for
Aesthetic so what is our shark and it
look like and then so if these are like
kind of the building blocks the
foundation of our chart what are we
actually doing with this foundation I
want to create a dot plot so I'm adding
using this plus operator into G on point
which is the function to create a dot
plot so if I run that here I'll have a
very generic plain-looking dot plot
there if I want to get fancy will fit
too sorry you could use piping here too
so it'd be sales data pipe into since
sales data it's a first argument to
ggplot then it would just be you don't
have to include that then it would just
be all this stuff so you can use piping
and everything once you attach to Depot
our package okay so that's a very basic
dot plot and ggplot um so now we have
our base thing we have our dot plot now
we can change colors and we could do
things will fit you can look at the
cheat sheet but how you would do that is
you just put in color inside the
aesthetic for to actual dot plot or to G
on point and change that to red and
you'll have that there okay and so I use
actual string red to change the colors
to red I do believe you can use like hex
code colors RGB and you do have to
change like some argument to specify
that you are using hex code so you're
not stuck with like red blue pink and so
forth okay so all I did was change the
color to red but now let's make it a
little more you know a little more
aesthetically pleasing and so I'm now
building from the same thing I added
another building block and which of my
labels will be so now I'm adding a title
X label Y label because I added a color
it added this legend here and I really
don't need that because there's only one
category of things and so I'm gonna
remove it using here okay and so that
will be two new ggplot and they're a
waste like center dis title and I don't
memorize or I don't know like any of
these off the top of my head he's like
arguments team like Legend position
color I I constantly have to refer back
to cheat sheet and so yeah if it seems
overwhelming like I never memorize it
like yeah thank God a box got to see the
cheat sheet on the exam yeah so don't
worry about having to know everything
off the top of your head okay and so now
if I wanted to add a regression line you
could see that everything before is the
same now I'm just adding a smoothing and
then you can see that it has a
regression line on there one cool thing
about ggplot in our studio very easy to
output into like a like a PNG file if
you want to put it in your report
all you do top bottom right export you
could copy to clipboard or save as image
and then very easy to do that okay so if
you want to put it in your report or
anything like that you can also create
bar charts pretty much any type of chart
like box and whiskers yeah you can see
all the examples here I'm not going to
list them but you can also do like a use
your dir data set that you group by
summarize mutated and you can send that
into ggplot and so I'm not going to go
through all this because you guys have a
good understanding of it now but all I'm
doing here it's finding out how many
belong to each status using this end
function if you don't remember from
earlier and is the same thing as count
how many belong to status and so I'm
getting my status data so I can
so disputed all that and my total
account which I named it here and then
I'm going to use that status data into
my ggplot and now I have a bar chart
with my status data and customized
accordingly you can do to all this I
mean I keep sound like a broken record
but you can do all this piping so if I
wanted to do all of it piping in one one
swoop I can just go like this
and then this will be the same thing as
above but all entirely by piping so
piping is a really powerful function it
saves a lot of time okay so I want to
give you guys some time to work on
question five and then also add any
customization you may want looking at
the cheat sheet try to decipher like
exactly what is it that you want and
then figure out from the cheechee how
you would when I said chichi I mean this
document right here and then make your
adjustments accordingly well you guys
the next because we only have 15 minutes
left we'll have next five minutes see
how far you guys can get and then we'll
have like closing marks any questions
after that so I'll give you this time to
work on question five
and notice its sales by product line so
you guys do have to do some group line
summarizing before you put it into
ggplot yeah
yeah you can make a you can make it 10 C
file yeah yeah see Tendo grams oh oh oh
you would use a different function to
great trees yeah yeah but you can do
that in our yeah yeah and if you're
confused on how to do something it's
always helpful to Google how to add axis
titles in ggplot and then they will
usually have some Stack Overflow exactly
how to do that oh yeah I would say it
you can do that but there are more row
butter better that yeah I would
recommend plotly Follies more
interactive as like JavaScript in there
so if I cover it'll have like a pop-up
yeah fusion charts that's really good I
know plot fusion charts man I'd have to
pay for commercial license
I think plot Lee's free yeah okay
nice yeah are you can create different
dashboards using are shiny it's like a
pretty cheap option depending on your
usage but I know I use that in my
previous company so yeah
if you finish question five feel free to
move on to question six and create any
chart you would like
yeah let me know if you have any
questions
if you guys about a minute to wrap up
and then we'll go through how you do it
just for your own documentation purposes
all right we'll bring it back together
so we want to figure out the product
line in the total sales per product line
so very first thing we want to do is do
a group I and summarize so we're
grouping it by the product line and then
we are summarizing it by our total sales
or our sales which is just the sum of
sales and then we want to create a bar
chart and so now I'm piping so I don't
need to put in that sales data and our X
is our product line our Y is our total
sales which is a new field we created
using the summarize statement and then
we want to create a bar chart so you
have to put in your identity or your
forget what stat stands it's just
something you have to do stat identity
and then see what it gives us here okay
so good so far but it also says we want
to have the outline of the bars red so
color is red and the fill equals pink
and so that would be a what it would
look like from the question what it's
asking but they're also a lot of things
that we can do with it to make a
prettier for example we can change these
access titles we can rotate rotate the
axle Able's you can google that figure
out how to rotate the x axis labels you
can easily do that but you could also
maybe if you want to remove the grid on
the outside and the inside a lot of
everything's trending towards minimalism
so having a little as there it's
possible you could change like the
numbers here instead of having the
scientific notation you can have it you
know use different notation for that so
there are a lot of different things you
can do to customize it we
about seven minutes left and they did
want to sweep five minutes for Q&A I
don't really know you guys could ask
whatever you want about our studio or
our four packages you can use or we can
you know if we have no questions and you
could use a remainder at this time for
you guys and continue working on this
exercise and playing with ggplot sir any
questions that you guys have yeah
yeah yeah that's that's a huge debate in
the day science community our verse
Python and I think it's it really comes
down to preference
I've from my experience if Python and
our people with programming backgrounds
find Python more intuitive because it's
object-oriented and a lot easier to
handle people without CS backgrounds
fine are more intuitive because you
really don't have to learn like what our
class is what I met this and things like
that it's very straightforward
you apply function get the output in
terms of processing both work in memory
so it's going to be very similar
performance I find that data sets a
similar-sized are going to run the same
speed in both are easily handles like
tables up to million to in the millions
of rows I'll handle that without a
problem but really just comes down to
preference both will have similar
functionality both will be able to do
the same machine learning similar
visualizations it's just who you are and
what you feel more comfortable with yeah
and your customer yeah I will say though
art does support our markdown and like
very easy to generate consumer friendly
reports yeah and so that aspect I will
say ours better but really it just comes
down to you know what your company wants
and who your clients are yeah
any other questions
yeah yeah um so I will say like my
opinion about machine learning and bas
feel free to chime in in our verse
Python R is a lot more fragmented
meaning you're gonna use like different
packages for different things like if
you want to run it random for so you can
have to use one package if you want to
run support vector machine you use
another package but in Python it's a lot
more standardized and that you're using
just scikit-learn for everything same
input same arguments but I would say
like in terms of functionality you're
gonna have the same same thing it's just
more fragmented in our yeah
yeah
yes okay so you're like interfacing with
like a sequel or like Oracle yeah there
are you can easily create like an open
database connection and write sequel
queries directly in our and then send it
to query your data or you can call
stored procedures in your your database
very friendly in doing so if you look up
like how to connect our to your database
whatever it is like Oracle you know my
sequel Microsoft sequel server you'll
find plenty of resources yeah
any other questions okay I think that we
got through everything which is I didn't
think we would which is awesome and I'll
give you guys two minutes back thank you
so much
[Applause]